and an absolutely special treat here we
are now joined
by world champion magnus carlson who who
got a victory that that you had me and
ben
talking magnus about uh about your
victories over levon aronian from the
sing phil cub way back and and other
games where you where you play on in a
situation where
you only needed a draw right are you
doing it doing it because you feel like
it's the right thing to do
do you do it for the fans how what was
going through your mind as you're
grinding out that victory when all you
needed was a draw to move on
i thought there was very very little
risk of losing
uh so that that's that was the main
reason
also i really feel like i need practice
in classical chess since i haven't
played
um played much at all in the in the last
uh one and a half years
yeah so yeah also since i'm playing a
world championship
later this year i i really needed uh
needed to practice so
in that sense it's uh it's good to play
some some longer games
yeah it makes sense you know ben was
also commenting on that point
seeing acro across the room fabiano
fabiano caruana lost uh to do me by
event and is going home and
and on that note do you feel that a lot
of the top players are maybe in the same
mindset of trying to work out some of
the rust some of the kinks because
obviously playing over the board chess
is different than than the online events
and is
is that part of your mindset right now
just to really shake off the rust of not
having not played over the board in a
while
oh yeah for sure um i i feel like i'm
still
uh a little bit iffy some sometimes
especially yesterday i was
was a bit uh a bit nervous but um
yeah i'm hope i'm hoping to to sort of
play myself
um into form hopefully i can get
get a lot of get a lot of games
ben yeah magnus i i just wanted to
congratulate you along with the other
players
this event seems a lot more interesting
um because there's so many good players
and the games are interesting because we
don't see any of those
really quick draws so this is this is
becoming really exciting for everybody
and i'm wondering if um you're surprised
at all by
how well some of the younger players are
doing or more surprised
it's how some of the older players are
doing in their 50s and they're still in
the tournament
yeah i think it just goes to to show
that
uh there are a lot of strong players
and also two games is
it's a really small sample size so the
variance is going to be
quite uh quite high um
obviously like everybody else i've been
very impressed with
um with uh with cinderella and the way
he's got he's gone about
um and it seems it seems to be
the same in in all of these uh
world cups that there there's always uh
going to be
[Music]
probably several breakouts breakout
stars
and looks like he's a good candidate to
to be the one one here but
as i said very
a lot of a lot of very tough
well-prepared opponents
uh here and i don't think anybody can
can feel sort of comfortable in any any
around
especially from now on
do you feel do you feel more comfortable
when everybody's
top 10 top 20 in the world which a lot
of the round robins are
or i think the fans like it better when
the top players
mix it up with people who are 100 200
points lower rated because they're
trying
more to win i think and they have an
advantage being better players and the
games are more interesting
um than just playing all the top players
in the world or do you
do you enjoy just playing the better
players because that's more of a test
for you
um no as you said in a way it's much
easier to play the same guys that i i
usually play
because i know them know them well and
i don't feel feel that pressure to
to win uh always so i can i can it's
easier to play your
your own uh own game um
but now
in general
yeah in general these events are they're
a lot of fun because
you get to to do something else
and even though
um yeah
even though
there are challenges to to playing to
playing these slightly
some of these slightly unfamiliar
barristers
still it's in in a way um
it's not 100 negative not to face the
same
the same players and to
to bang your head against berlin walls
or
or similar every time so
i mean well we uh we greatly
greatly appreciate your time magnus you
are you are currently the
you are the only player to have won all
their games so far and
in either section and so we we wish you
the best of luck i know i speak for
everyone and that we
hope to see you playing in sochi all the
way all the way to the end and
um best of luck in in round four enjoy
enjoy two rest stage
what are you gonna do with two rest days
what's the plan um
hopefully i'll go for uh for a hike in
the mountains like
i i injured my foot playing football uh
one and a half weeks ago
hopefully it's about fine now so i can
do that
i will say however the last time i
played the world cup
um i was the only player at 4-0
and i i lost in the third round so i'm
hoping
it's not gonna not gonna happen again
well well good luck uh we don't wanna
jinx you enjoy enjoy the football and uh
thank you again thank you again for
joining us
thanks magnus that was great